bonsoir et bien au centre d'italie que
ce soir un sujet qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur je veux parler
des femmes
je vais tout d'abord vous présenter les
invités d'italie je commencerai par
francis lacassin
edgar morin
il est accompagné ce soir par sa femme
je râle
georges teboul qui ne veut pas qu'on
dise qu'il est médecin mais il est quand
même
claude du granrut
romain gary je ne vous apprendrai pas
qu'ils les cinéastes
hélène fin qu elle
est madame hélène teboul des médecins
elle aussi
hélène de boules
où vous allez préfacé un très très beau
livre
dont je dois dire qu'il est le premier
depuis très longtemps être signé d'un
psychologue
et que je le lise du début à la fin
presque je dirais pas comme un roman
policier ce n'est pas un roman policier
puisque son titre c'est les femmes mais
que j'ai l'impression à travers ce livre
de
de découvrir des choses que je ne savais
pas et de formuler de pouvoir formuler
enfin des choses que je ne formuler pas
auparavant alors je crois que c'est très
important
je veux la question qui me vient tout de
suite c'est pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez particulièrement fait une préface à
ce livre pourquoi vous
je crois que il me l'a demandé au niveau
de l'amitié qui est née d'une une
collaboration puisque nous exerçons des
métiers et que de la collaboration est
née une rencontre
et lorsqu'il a parlé de ce livre à peu
près deux ans avant sa parution
nous en avons fait un psychologue belge
comment exactement
psychanalyste est extrêmement connue
nous en avons vus ensemble la nécessité
il nous est apparu à travers nos
expériences respectives que parler en
termes de scientifiques disent que je
suis important qui est l'envoi ce
actuelle du couple qui ne se trouvent
pas devenait urgent
je veux dire que la lecture de ce livre
lecture d'un autre livre aussi qui est
place aux femmes donc l'hôte du grand
rite nous parlera tout à l'heure
vraiment je crois que ce soit on a envie
de parler des femmes alors claude durand
ruth vous même pourquoi avez vous fait
ce livre
bien je crois que on porte les femmes
portent beaucoup d'idées et font une
espèce de thésaurus d'un certain nombre
d'idées qu'elle accumule au fur et à
mesure des jours des travaux qu'elles
font et qu'un beau jour il faut que ça
sorte et c'est sorti et je veux dire si
sortie que steam calais et moi nous
avons eu envie de faire ce livre parce
que nous avions l en tant que
journaliste ou en tant qu'économiste
nous avions amassé un certain nombre de
connaissances et nous avons décidé de
vérifier d'abord nos connaissances sur
le terrain car chacune dans notre dans
notre style nous avions une bonne
connaissance mois du travail des femmes
par des statistiques je savais qu'il y
avait presque un million de plus de
femmes qui travaillaient il y en a 8
millions maintenant ils avaient 7
millions il ya quelques années je savais
qu'il y avait des cartes je savais qu'il
y avait des ouvrières des tables des os
je savais qu'il y avait des gens polis
plein de secrétaire mais ce que je ne
savais pas c'est comment elle vivait
alors je savais qu'elle avait la vie
difficile et je suis allé avec christine
voir partout en france
si ce que nous avions d'une comme idée
sur leurs problèmes sur leur vie
quotidienne et s était la vérité et nous
avons découvert alors la dmass deux
choses d'abord on a eu quelques
vérifications de nos idées mais aussi on
a découvert une énorme solidarité une
énorme résident d'énergie d'amour de
deux volontés de fraternité entre ces
femmes qui travaillent et nous les avons
fait parler et nous avons essayé de les
faire parler dans ce livre est bien sûr
de noter au fur et à mesure qu'elle nous
parle elle les problèmes qu'elle a fait
et comment elle avait essayé de les
résoudre un problème de garde d'enfants
bien sûr les problèmes de hiérarchie se
heurte tout le temps la hiérarchie et la
hiérarchie des hommes et le monde du
travail est un monde fait pour les
hommes et par les armées puis elles sont
quand même indispensable elle 108
millions qui travaillent et à tous les
échelons alors on a parlé avec elle et
on a vu que beaucoup d'entre elles
avaient besoin de ce changement est beau
et c'est là où je reviens un petit peu
au livre de dako c'est que ce travail
leur apporte beaucoup de choses
tout d'un coup elle se révèle elle
accumule des tas de choses qu'elle avait
en elle qui n'était pas très bien
formulée et salé détermine ça pose des
problèmes avec le marquis beaucoup de
problèmes avec le marais avec la société
avec le patron avec elle mène d'abord
sans doute mais une fois qu'elles ont
résolu ça l est sont changés je vous
assure elles sont différentes elles sont
heureuses sont forts et je crois que
c'est ce que c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
dire dans mon livre j'aimerais savoir
c'est que hélène pourrait dire là dessus
je crois que ce que vous dites et qui
montre à quel point le travail
est nécessaire et non pas suffisant à la
femme pour devenir un être
et tout à fait impressionnant est ce que
vous disiez en d'autres termes c'est que
la femme est prisonnière d'une demande
et d'un rôle l'opinion lui demandent de
se conformer
à ce que molière écrivait très bien il
ya très longtemps
en dehors de cela en dehors de cette
espèce d'honorabilité ou et sa dignité
sinon là où vous le mettez
vous avez dit nécessaire le travail mais
pas suffisant oui voudraient que vous
expliquer un peu là dessus c'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire hausser reçu
un être qui existe sur tout et presque
exclusivement
par le rôle que la tradition lui donne
le travail lui donnera
une possibilité d'un devenir autonome et
autonomie veut dire bien autre chose que
licence
mais ça ne suffit pas parce que même la
femme qui travaille
lorsqu'elle dit j'espère que je rends
mon mari heureux qu'est ce qu'elle veut
dire que l'opinion patriarcale
lui a mis cela
personnellement je ne crois pas beaucoup
qu'on puisse rendre quelqu'un heureux
comme cela si na pas l'aptitude au
bonheur mais quel sens enfin cela de
voir tellement profond que c'est par
rapport à cela qu'elle se vit avec tous
les problèmes de culpabilité qu'elle
peut il mettre le jeu dans votre dans
votre vie professionnelle
qui n'est pas honteux de dire que les
tic analystes croient que vous vous
occupez beaucoup de femmes votre mari
aussi d'ailleurs
alors en ce moment
qu'elle est par exemple le problème que
les femmes viennent vous apportez quel
est le problème le plus fréquent
est ce que c'est par exemple le problème
de leur libération puisqu'on parle
beaucoup de libération de la femme je
crois que celles qui viennent me voir
ont dépassé depuis longtemps ce petit
jeu de la guerre ça ne les intéresse
absolument pas lorsqu'elle parlait en
termes de conflits c'était pour avoir le
droit d'exister en tant qu'être ça c'est
pas ça du tout ça se passe ce qu'elles
viennent chercher
c'est pourquoi elles et leurs maris
se croisent et ne se rencontrent pas
elles viennent parce qu'elles sont mal à
l'aise c'est la question du mal être ce
que mon collègue et néanmoins marie
rencontre beaucoup au niveau hospitalier
dans
la maladie ce que l'on appelle
communément la maladie oui
dit que l'on peut dire c'est le cri de
l'être humain qui est allié n'est pas
son rôle justement et dans une
consultation hospitalière de gynécologie
nous voyons des femmes somatisé
c'est-à-dire souffrir terriblement
nouveau de leur corps au niveau de ce
qui est simplement une souffrance
douleur être et j'ai un cas est
extraordinaire c'est tout à fait raison
c'est qu'une femme a été opérée par
exemple si x été littéralement ouverte
six fois au sujet de bien sûr de lésions
qui existait aussi au niveau d'eau vers
au niveau d'une opération de trompes au
niveau
de ménorragies etc mais elle a été
opérée six fois parce qu'elle souffrait
réellement et à la sixième fois elle
hurlé autant de douleur dans demain et
bien cette femme qui était pris aux
psychothérapies elle souffrait
terriblement de ne pas assumer sa
féminité de ne pas de mal être dans sa
peau pourrait dire tout simplement et
après avoir été apaisées dans sa
reconnaissance à féminité sa
reconnaissance dans le fait qu'elle est
reconnue par l'autre c'est à lire aussi
par le mari qui lui refuse presque
toujours de venir voir le
psychothérapeute parce que bien sûr
c'est la femme qui est malade lui n'a
rien à voir soini moi ma femme n'est ce
pas cc c'est le cri veut plus et bien et
je veux et quant à marie me dis ça je
dis monsieur elle vous permettez qu'on
s'occupe d'abord et avant tout nouveau
problème
oui il aime ta gueule cet empêchement
à l'hectare complet oui ça s'agite ça
oui les femmes n'ont pas le droit d'être
un état complet ça dépasse largement le
la revendication c'est simplement un
état de fait qui est nécessaire de
dépasser ce serait que voyez-vous dans
le livre de pierre jaccaud d'ailleurs on
le sent venir comment peut-on
trouver la solution de ce dépassement
est ce que c'est aussi en guérissant les
sommes
pas à la solidarité
je suis convaincu que ce problème du
rôle
est aussi celui de l'homme
le problème du du superman a dit bien
mais vous faites allusion à un livre
d'hélène morgan qui appelle la fin
plusieurs vannes
lorsque adam s'en va du paradis
terrestre
f derrière est une bonne épouse et elle
tricote aileron chan mais c'est adam qui
choisit la direction ce n'est pas m sa
sève l'oubli quelquefois moi je pense
que
l'homme et la femme ont légal problème
de de se libérer d'un tas de poncifs qui
qui les oblige à se vivre deux
extrémités je n'ai pas la toxicologie
qui n'est pas tellement différente au
sens où l'homme a une composante
féminine
et la femme une composante masculine et
qui ne pourra y avoir de rencontre que
dans la limite où enfin il prendre une
distance vis-à-vis de l'opinion
bien sûr je crois qu'on est un peu dans
les termes généraux le froid qu'il
faudrait revenir plus spécifiquement
crois que club du grand ried veut dire
quelque chose oui je veux dire que je me
trouve un petit peu pessimiste
personnellement je serais quand même
plus optimiste
peut-être parce que j'ai ramassé un
certain nombre de devis de vie heureuse
de vie réussie de vie avec des problèmes
en fin de vie quand même plus plus
complète qui était sans doute complété
par par un problème qui sort la femme
d'elle-même qui l'a fait lutter contre
cette espèce de coop un peu vide sur
laquelle on sait que la société a bâti
pour elle et dans laquelle elle est
obligée de se mouvoir un peu au début
mais quand elle sort de sa coque quand
elle sort de chez elle d'ailleurs le
phénomène n'est pas si extraordinaire
c'est que les femmes à voir ne sortez
pas de chez elle pour travailler
maintenant elles sortent de chez elles
donc elles sont obligées de se
confronter de s'affronter avec un mot et
c'est comme ça que peu à peu le monde
bien à elle elle aussi elle accumule des
richesses et
je crois que
elle ne sait pas quelle lutte contre
contre les hommes elles ont envie de
changer ce système de travail elles ont
envie et bien sûr il faut d'abord qu'ils
accumulent un certain nombre
d'expériences mais à partir du moment où
les accusés ont accumulé un certain
nombre d'expériences il n'y a pas de
raison elles ont elles ont envie de
changer le travail elles ont envie de
changer même de travail est
abominablement rigide de huit heures par
jour de complet comme ça enfin c'est
grotesque plus quatre heures de de
transport et et elle se mènent des vies
épouvantable avec des enfants dont il
faut qu'elle s'occupe dîner le marché
des transferts s'est dit que c'est ça
c'est l'os et le handicap mais ce
handicap elle elle le surmonte à partir
d'un certain moment parce que justement
maintenant il ya une chose nouvelle
c'est qu'avant quand elle travaille elle
travailler deux ou trois ans que ce
mariage un enfant arrêter maintenant
elle travaille pour toute leur vie donc
elles sont obligées de mettre une
dimension nouvelle dans leur vie qui est
le travail et je dois dire que quand on
est une dimension ce fait une victime de
plus on marche plus aisément on a quand
même plus d'autorité chez soi sur son
mari parfois sur ses enfants aussi mes
enfants de femmes qui travaillent je
crois sont tassés de robin sait pas ce
qu'en penserait
je crois que ma garde il ya quelque
chose à poser une question je suis
personnellement je sais pas je suis
peut-être sacrilège mais je suis plutôt
ennemis du travail il ne paraît pas plus
la vocation de l'homme soit voué au
travail je voudrais je voudrais qu'on
m'explique ce qu'on entend dans ce
contexte par travail est ce que on
entend de l'accomplissement de la
vocation d'une femme à faire ce qui lui
plaît dans la vie et incidemment choisir
une activité puisque vous entendez par
travail le gagne-pain parce que pour moi
cela même pas rien depuis dans ce siècle
depuis le siècle
du 19e avec une sacralisation du travail
qu'ils le fassent quand en 2001 et qui
est une des malédictions de ce temps
c'est un un puritanisme absolument
atroce bouleversant et dont on n'ose pas
démystifier parce qu'on risque de
toucher à la classe ouvrière et aidera
d'annoter la valeur guide sacré de la
bourgeoisie qu'est ce qui n'est pas tant
de voir exactement en quoi pourquoi ce
travail qui sanctifie nobilise libère
est ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce que ce
soit autrement dit quand vous posez
d'une manière qui me paraît indiscutable
la femme a besoin de 50 pire selon ses
avocats sion comme elle l'entend par son
activité puisque il n'y a pas là un
danger des rimes le secure tombe
exactement dans le même piège que
l'homme c'est-à-dire le casse croûte et
tout le reste obligatoire pour survivre
ont surnagé avec l'eau qui arrive là là
là alors je ne vois pas en quoi sa
dignité ou sa féminité trouverait à
s'accomplir en même temps est ce qu'on
peut demander à edgar morin qui s'est
beaucoup penché sur les problèmes de
travail qui est l'auteur d'un livre qui
s'appelle la la la famille majeur
non enfin moi je pense que ce que dit
terry tout est juste mais je veux dire
qu'il ya aussi l'autre aspect de la
question et qui serait celui ci c'est
que il faut partir d'abord d'une
condition de la femme paysanne accablé
de labeur et qui a inspiré à être la
femme au foyer bon et c'était gagné une
autonomie et puis dès qu'on arrive au
stade de la femme au foyer celle ci
s'est vu enfermé confuse et hors du
monde et l'inspiré de travailler et pour
elle travaille et c'est sortir une sorte
de prison du foyer mais dès qu'elles
travaillent effectivement non seulement
elle a des contacts évidemment qui vont
intéresser dans le monde mais elle va
subir des contraintes avec masculin et
je dirais même pire parce que le temps
chronométrique déjà très dur pour
l'homme est encore plus brutal pour la
femme qui est des cycles biologiques
beaucoup plus ample et risque la va
commencer par les cycles menstruels et
puis les grandes cycle quand elle
atteindra enceinte alors moi je trouve
que la femme est engagée à ce niveau là
dans l'acheminement où chaque fois je
trouve une solution qu'elle est amenée à
vouloir dépasser c'est ça qui est très
fécond aujourd'hui dans une danseuse
dans ce phénomène je crois que les
femmes est en marche 1 à travers des
expériences diverses qui apporte quelque
chose et puis qui se révèlent décevantes
cette mise en marche oblige la société a
bougé et ses sages du point de vue
social
je crois qu'à trop dur on veut dire
quelque chose je suis tout à fait de
votre avis et ses voeux les femmes ont
le souci de cela bien sûr il ya la main
pour fermes encore ont besoin la société
est ainsi fait qu'on a besoin de
travailler pour gagner son pain mais ce
qu'il ya de si extraordinaire c'est que
depuis deux ans les mouvements
deux femmes les mouvements de femmes qui
travaillent sont justement pour baisser
les cadences les zones ont assez de ces
cadences stupide qui les crève qui les
tue qui leur escale les yeux qu'il est
fatigué qui les rend nerveuse il
obligeait fondé et vous avez toutes les
grèves les plus intéressants sur le plan
sociologique actuellement sont des
grèves de femmes qui préfèrent gagner
moins mais ne pas se fatiguer ne pas se
tuer et vous savez que ce sont les
premières jamais vous n'aviez de grève
comme cela ce sont les premiers à avoir
fait des grèves des deux cas dans ce que
vous dites est capital parce que nous
entrons dans une contribution dans le
domaine contribution essentielle la
femme qui est d'après ce qu'indique la
féminisation du travail moi je souhaite
la féminisation du monde un jeune à
votre compte la monstruosité de
l'additionnel du machisme qui
personnellement ne sort pas grandie
qu'arthur dans l'art dans la vie est
partout la féminisation du lourd devant
justement pranger prêter attention à ce
que vous dites c'est extra venus a
raison de défendre contre les quinze ans
de travail qui quand elle est première
ce que j'appelle le début de la
féminisation du monde
à travailler moins longtemps avec des
horaires plus ou des horaires variables
ce sont elles qui le demandent et elles
savent pourquoi moi j'ai envie d'avoir
que
j'ai envie d'avoir le la vie des lampes
bull et de son mari par exemple nous
vivons une époque où il n'est question
que
d'érotisme que de pornographie que enfin
à tous les niveaux bon
à ce niveau là il y a les femmes ce
groupe les femmes veulent se libérer les
femmes exige l'égalité est ce qu'ils se
posent un problème d'égalité entre
hommes et femmes c'est là que je
voudrais m'en venir quand on sait le
siège bagarre quant à leur vie
[Rires]
donc partout partout partout du
fondement
alors parfois la balle
vous avez une somme qui a grosso modo de
duras de femme
la femme assez bête pour ne jamais avoir
souhaité de sa vie être un homme et dont
je suis
et la femme qui
ne se pense pas ce qu'elle n'en vit pas
ne se pense qu'avec des mots d'un
destin d'homme et cela effectivement
rentrerez dans
ce qu'on pourrait appeler un des
bandages vous dites érotisme je dis
vraiment je ne prostitueraient pas ses
mots qui est pour moi vous très je me
plonge dans mon d'essence a su c'est
très très grave c'est au fond la
pesanteur et la grâce et je le dis très
sérieusement
pour une famille mais certains manière
votre question ne se pose pas elle vit
cela comme elle respire avec autant de
simplicité naturelle et avec un mot peut
être très très idiot trade autrefois une
espèce de pureté animal rien sur ma
question était on parle tout le temps de
d'égalité d'infériorité donc de
supériorité est ce que le problème se
pose réellement et le boul quant à ce
domaine horizontale quant à la vie quant
à la ville quant à la vie
fait semblant de ne pas comprendre la
foulée monde et
le chat va bien je crois que
ça se passe tout à fait ailleurs
l'égalité la super y est la supériorité
l'infériorité ce sont vraiment des mots
ou de bascule ou de compétition or vous
savez une amazone
pas nous sommes des hommes
et ce sont des mots qui ne sont pas
propres à la femme ce sont des mots qui
sont crois que cela va
poser enfin absolument absolument est ce
que je tout à l'heure j'ai essayé de
dire c'est que finalement le merveilleux
de la femme et de son temps de son temps
de respiration naturelle qu'elle est en
train
de passer à l'homme pour lui permettre
de souffler un peu plus loin si vous
permettez l'image justement lui
permettre ce pauvre adam bâ de
ressembler tout simplement un être
humain et dans sortie
d'en sortir pour reprendre votre
question je pense que vraiment ça ça
part tout à fait ailleurs ce sont des
mots les mots vous donner pour la femme
n'ont pas de sens ça n'a pas de sens
tout simplement c'est insensé
je trouve d'ailleurs cette cheveux pour
entrer en compétition je profite de
votre présence pour satisfaire la
curiosité jada bien personne ne jamais
répondre on a inventé pour les femmes un
terme qui apparaît toujours absolument
qu'ils soient techniques l'a9 man bon
neuf matches se trouve vision d'homme
d'une certaine que tu n'as jamais dit
quoi une chose en réalité les vrais
l'informant que ce sont les hommes
quantité d'hommes qui sont un phénomène
absolument prodigieux mais que pourquoi
n'existe pas un terme pour les âmes
symétrique du pot 9 manne pour la femme
comment dit-on d'un homme qui ne fane on
veut pas dire de nom
on peut dire qu'il a une jolie voiture
et qu'il est très riche c'est certain
c'est lui qui permettra aussi de réponse
on ne tombe pas des gens qui se penche
pas sur la nymphomanie sur le mode
égalité moche au g qu'il faut faire très
attention
le mot égalité est un mode homme dans la
mesure où signifie identité dans la
mesure on suppose que l'égalité ça veut
dire que la femme doit être identique un
homme méchant que le mot égalité un sens
très profond dans la mesure où il veut
dire que il faut essayer de supprimer
cette hiérarchie sociale collective qui
fait que dans de nombreux secteurs où
considère que ce que l'homme est
supérieur ou que les valeurs viriles son
supérieur ça c'est important mais la
différence entre femmes norme doit
s'épanouir sur un plan légal mais
restait la différence tout en demeurant
ce que vous avez très bien dit c'est que
nous pourrons dire le guen dans la
mesure où l'homme n'aura plus compte de
sa part féminine en lui ou l'art foulera
plus et où la femme pour a exprimé aussi
sa part masculine mais cette différence
restera parce que nous resterons de
façon dominante un peu plus haut mais
que les femmes restant un peu plus forte
c'est ce que pierre dac haut avec l'eau
de rim dans son chapitre sur la
bisexualité et bien sûr et qui est à
l'origine de toutes les découvertes
mycologique de freud et jung alors que
le terme
il s'agit de deux supériorités
l'espace d'un père
[Musique]
différent et de plans parfaitement
complémentaires ce qui est ce qui est
souhaitable c'est que cette
complémentarité se réalise ne soient pas
systématiquement
de la bloquer je ne vous ai pas présenté
mais vous êtes parmi nous disons la
lectrice elle qui a lu dako qui a lu
clauses du granrut qui a lui également
le livre de d'evelyne sullerot qui
s'appelle les françaises au travail
alors entraînements du genou soit
l'auteur ou sucre ne peut mieux
parce que vous avez vous parlé des
enchanteurs qui est votre dernière en
vigueur dans les raves et vous
participez à la discussion vous regardez
à quel point vous êtes pour beaucoup
d'être la part de même qui leur a permis
de respirer dans une vie où ne respire
pas vous ne diriez pas cela jamais je
n'ai jamais gentil s'était vraiment ce
que je sais
à cette égalité monsieur me gratte un
peu
je vous
aimerai économique il ya le problème de
base de riz noir et un travail légal
tâche égal le salaire rien et s'est
enquis et déjà qu'il est joli mais
réglementaire mais qu'on ne peut pas et
qui n'est pas dépassé quelques jours le
danger de cela est ce que les américains
appellent dans le domaine de la guerre
réservé comme d'état dire on a tué trop
de meurtres d'hommes pour le résultat
recherché la femme est obligée pour se
libérer il ya une certaine part de pau
verdier ne t'oblige et d'en faire plus
parce que ça économiquement et
socialement de pouvoir et ça enfin des
risques terribles de traumatismes
également parce que je connais dans
cette lutte de femmes qui sont d'une
agressivité d'une hostilité dirigées par
par notre faute oui elles sont
quelquefois agressé quelques fois ils se
sentent coupables aussi alors elle se
met à tout faire pour être bien pour
être des bonnes mères pourraient être
des travailleuses car elle travaille ce
sont de remarquables ouvriers se sont de
remarquables des employés avant les
secrétaires sont en général de bonne
secrétaire
elle essaie de tout fait mais je crois
qu'à partir du moment où elles se disent
que si stupide de tout faire alors là la
partie est gagnée mais jusque là il ya
effectivement un gâchis affreux de
potentialités elle ne trouve pas
l'emploi qui devrait les
les épanouir elle ne trouve pas elles
sont elles sont harcelés par beaucoup de
tâches elles sont harcelés par des
tâches où ils n'ont pas tellement de
responsabilités mais
nous sentons et je sens de plus en plus
c'est avec le livre d'edgar morin on
sent vraiment que maintenant les femmes
bougent seuil elles sont parties elles
sont partis par le travail peut-être
c'est pas suffisant je ne crois pas que
ce soit suffisant mais c'est un c'est un
moyen a été un moyen pour elle de
démarrer josé et en plus de ça toutes
sont confrontés à la même chose toutes
les femmes même celles qui travaillent
par elles sont confrontées indirectement
au travail je voudrais poser une
question au docteur teboul
je vais je vais réagir en mail
chauviniste est ce que en fait la
découverte de la femme
dans sa vérité est ce qu'il n'ya pas
nécessité d'effectuer un grand travail
sur l'homme
en même temps tout reprendre vos termes
tout à l'heure je voudrais vous
développiez un peu écoutez je pense que
pierre dac aulas très bien exprimé dans
justement le chapitre sur la bisexualité
où à chaque homme correspond une
composante féminine et à chaque femme
une composante masculine et c'est dans
cette étude mais alors dans cette étude
qui demandent un temps fou et je suis
parti deux minutes méditerranéen où
l'homme était conçue bien sûr comme le
pater comme le le patriarche comme le
maître comme le directeur de conscience
comme le responsable de toute la famille
avec bien entendu le rôle de la femme
qui est celle qui apporte comme le
disait je connais le bonheur aussi aux
enfants et aux maris et à à partir de ce
point de départ j'ai opéré un
cheminement extraordinaire parce que
j'étais d'accord pour que ma femme ne
travaille pas et j'étais d'accord pour
que ma femme s'occupe des enfants et je
n'avais que cette conception et si je
n'avais pas rencontré cette étude
psychologique
passionnant
j'en serai encore à ce stade dans lequel
nous vivons parce que tout la télévision
la publicité tout confine la femme dans
cet être de dalles de cet être féminin
c'est à d'évaporer vannes et sans que
tous contribuent et quand vous voulez
parler de vigueur vous présentez une
machine à laver palombes et qu'une
solide paysanne mais norme qui n'a rien
de film
je crois qu'effectivement il ya le
travail de yaya une interrogation du
couple alors sur pour pour résoudre tous
ces problèmes et je crois que le cours
ne peut se retrouver qu'à l'intérieur
cette de cette étude monsieur la
bisexualité qui fait que la
communication devient possible je crois
qu elle n que vous le foot est quelque
chose parce que je crois que l'heure
tourne
je vais simplement dire que je ne suis
pas tout à fait de votre avis la partie
n'est pas gagnée madame je pense que
elle commence seulement elle commence
mal à démarrer c'est déjà ça ou alors ça
oui c'est déjà bien mais c'est
maintenant que ça commence le j'ai
annoncé que je n'ai pas du tout amusant
maintenant on ne peut plus faire
autrement que de le lancer l'homme et la
femme la halle à côté de l'autre devant
leur vie
et c'est pas simple pour reprendre ce
mode tout à l'heure il y a une chose
qu'il faut dire c'est que les gros fait
sociologique le langage et la religion
sont défaits d'hommes
pourquoi est ce que les femmes étaient
agressifs mais elle ne faisait que ça
elle répétait le langage et le
comportement d'homme c'est beaucoup plus
à une simple tendance naturelle
on accuse de la
sentir une civilisation de 2001 de 5000
à force
revaloriser la notion je ne dirais pas
de faiblesse parce que le la place est
devenue une notion insultante et
péjorative lorsqu'on dit que quelqu'un
est faible ce tunnel même si vous dites
une une main c'est devenu un régulier
s'agit n'avait valoriser des notions de
féminité de notion de masse de notions
je mets du jeu ne rougirait pas dû dire
selon le notion de tendresse les 12
sièges
cornet vient du chemin et excusez moi
mais cette notion précisément je dois
dire que je la sens très bien dans votre
livre romain gary les enchanteurs
il ya tous ces personnages finalement
dans une société qui est une société
qui prend un personnage
en russie et qui le suit pendant toute
son existence je dois dire que la
lecture de ce livre
j'ai retrouvé
comme un ami enfin j'ai retrouvé un
romain gary lui depuis votre dernier
ouvrage je dois dire que ce livre qui
s'appelle donc les enchanteurs qui ne
m'érigerai que nous rendiez simplement
quelques mots je dirais simplement ceci
alors au risque peut-être de faire rire
certains spectateurs très attachés comme
dans disait à propos de l'ingénierie
revenus de leur poitrine cette virilité
qui pour moi s'exprime un peu comme ça à
vous comprenez
dire puisque le docteur a fait référence
à cette composante féminine chez nous
tous chez moi elle est très marquée et
de l'est très marqué d'une manière qui
est purement émotionnelle et affective
puisque tout de suite immédiatement
vient à l'esprit toutes sortes de
plaisanteries douteuses dans le contexte
du corps-de-garde comparé deux
composantes féminité renault je n'ai
rien craindre à ce souffle alors je
voulu mettre dans ce livre un maximum de
l'inspiration de ma composantes
masculine à la composante semaine pour
moi la féminité c'est parti d'une
manière tragique transcende complètement
toutes les sexualités bouchard
la féminité fait partie d'une des plus
belles choses d'une des plus admirables
chose de la création c'est une chose qui
pour moi constitue l'épanouissement de
la plus dans le botté que jusqu'au bout
sur la terre jeu voir dans 11 ans 70
jeunes et dans les enchanteurs
le sort ce que je ne dis pas mon amour
de la femme parce que c'est presque une
femme imaginaire donc maintenant mais
mon amour de la féminité mon aspiration
à la féminité c'est vraiment le cri du
coeur de la composante a souligné vous
féminisé attendait la maternité lattes
et tendresse la faiblesse la sensibilité
l'horreur du coup de poing l'horreur de
l'expo need et leurs hordes l'ecstasy
c'est ce que j'appelle la composante de
l'état il est temps que cette ces deux
composantes qui composent l'être humain
kitchen afagnan composantes masculine
jeune on est encore présente il est
temps qui est une synthèse de
civilisation baiser sur deux ces deux
composantes et non pas simplement sur le
machisme de la composante masculine peut
vraiment
vous peut plus tolérer je vous dis
encore ni dans l'art ni dans littérature
ni dans la et c'est ce que j'ai sur le
banc blanche romain gary romain gary qui
sont les enchanteurs les enchanteurs à
l'origine alors le canevas de nombreux
sont les saltimbanques italien vénitien
plus exactement qui sont allés en russie
sous catherine ii mais que vous le savez
je parle à la première personne
c'était clair 63 ans puisque ce sont des
charlatans le charlatan qui dit jeu
fausse 15 haga se prétend immortel parce
qu'ils la charge d'amour et mieux en ce
moment encore maintenant il écrit ça
comme de me voir comme une
autobiographie évidemment ce n'est pas
moi le personnage quand j'écris un roman
je cherche à m'éloigner de mon âme le
plus possible retrouvez le reste du
board sortir de la claustrophobie du
mois je crée des personnages parce que
j'ai besoin de ne pas être moi même et
cet homme vit donc un très grand amour
c'est en écrivant ce livre j'ai moi même
par procuration vécu ces trois grands un
mot pour thérèse unac et le personnage
féminin de la fin mais j'ai cherché
vraiment exprimé dans le livre qui est
picard s absolue d'une histoire d'
aventure et puisque peu à peu le dernier
des aga le dernier de ces saltimbanques
de viande qui sont inquiétés des
illusionnistes
la tradition de sur boulay de l'époque
des casanova re de tous les blocs de
zinc et de tous ces personnages
picaresques lesage peu à peu ces
illusionnistes se met au goût du jour et
devient artiste écrivain etc et ce n'est
pas dit dans le sens péjoratif
parce que justement je voulais marquer
que l'artiste n'est pas simplement une
illusion nist et c'est un livre qui
était écrit assez d'une manière très
critique envers le personnage qu'il joue
il faut transcender et dépasser
justement le rôle que joue le personnage
à travers l'histoire de l'artiste
amuseurs amis divertisseurs et
enchanteur si vous voulez il faut aller
un peu plus là nous entrons justement
dans le contexte tout à fait ce que j'en
sors c'est que dans la mesure je voulu
donner le meilleur de moi même dans ce
livre d'un cette arrivée au séminaire
que j'ai horreur de marée de mon côté
masculin il n'empêche que l'amour
que le personnage principal et prouve
pour sa belle-mère finalement vous le
décrivez effectivement comme si vous
l'aviez vécu d'une réunion
extraordinaire le groupement que je
l'écris j'écris pour vivre j'écris des
romans pour ceux d'être moi même d'être
quelque chose qu'ils tombent différents
jeux vraiment profondément avec lui la
lourde chose qu'à porteriez nage était
originale jai désespérés avec le
personnage c'est un livre d'amour est
pas là que je les écris g mais j'aimais
profondément
je dois dire qu'en dehors de l'écrivain
romain gary à l'homme romain gary aussi
qui me passionne cet homme m'a dit il
n'ya pas très longtemps une phrase que
je voudrais répéter si vous me le
permettez
le cnom qui m'avait dit j'ai raté un
mariage et j'ai réussi un divorce
je vous en prie vous savez moi je n'ai
rien qu'un jeu sont très belles c'est
c'est très difficile
jules est admirable je le dis je peux le
dire je crois que mon ex épouse de vingt
six jours nous avons réussi à venir
c'est une des grandes questions de la
civilisation occidentale
à mesure au fur et à mesure le divorce
multiples il devient plus facile
il est absolument indispensable là
encore le transcender ce côté c'est bête
qui apparaissent qui se déchaîne dans
les jambes et qui a divorce la
transformation des êtres vous avez vu
certainement sans madame le docteur
l'exercice de leur profession
l'apparition des bêtes sauvages le
divorce dès que le couple commence à
déverser l'apparition de monstres qu'on
ne soupçonnait même pas est quelque
chose qui est totalement faux ce qui
fait que l'on parle de réussir des
mariages mais il faut parler aussi la
réussite de divorce mais je crois qu'on
va parler maintenant changeant
complètement de sujets je crois qu'il
est temps maintenant de parler d'un
personnage n'est plus parmi nous mais je
crois que celui qui vient en parler le
sang comme quelqu'un de vivant il s'agit
d'un écrivain il s'agit de jack london
et c'est francis lacassin qui va en
parler jean-jacques brochier oui je
crois qu'on va passer une société
archaïque
probablement beaucoup plus dur parce que
plus simple et
plus tôt de parler de psychologie on va
parler de politique d'économie et
d'histoire de gîtes ou koué vie tout
court et jack london d'actions et
d'opérations en le pense sans arrêt
selon le coeur enfance michael sheen
cirque croc blanc le grand nord le chien
dressé tout c'est espèce de mythologie
un petit peu l'humaniste et 1,2
poisseuse
et puis on s'aperçoit que jack london a
aussi écrit le talent de faire les
wagons du rail martin eden c'est à dire
sa vie réelle une vie extrêmement dur
qui était jack london si vous me permets
de si vous permettez de jouer un petit
peu les provocateurs je dirais que il
serait certainement
très intimidé d'être parmi nous ce soir
car il ne ressemble à aucun d'entre nous
- y compris bien entendu car c'est un
personnage qui personne n'a pris à lire
il a appris à lier au tout seul car dans
l'icône où il était le maître ne pouvait
pas se livrer à son enseignement il
était toujours livrer les plus grands
élèves le battait et se venger sur les
plus petits alors jacques landon donc
est un personnage fraternelle chaleureux
qui s'est formé lui-même et qui a une
vie très courte à laquelle il a mis fin
à sa propre volontaires l'âge de 40 ans
et en ces quarante années il a trouvé le
temps d'écrire la fois 50 de vivre
d'être crieur de journaux marchand de
glaces pêcheurs pilleurs d'huîtres
policiers chargés de réprimer les
pilleurs d'huîtres chasseurs de phoques
ouvrier dans une centrale électrique
clochard pendant neuf mois il a parcouru
les états unis le canada à pied en
mendiant pendant neuf mois il a été
ensuite écrivain et ça n'a pas marché
les rangs devenus de nouveaux ouvriers
et enfin il a été chercheur d'or dans le
grand nord correspondant de guerre de la
plupart des guerres qui se déroulait de
son temps et finalement
humaniste sa mesure qui à sa manière
puisque il a adhéré au parti socialiste
il a été également l'un des
conférenciers l'une des personnalités
les plus prestigieuses du parti
socialiste amérique nous passons en
oublie que l'amérique à cette époque la
connaissait des luttes extrêmement
féroce violents et que le parti
socialiste était en fait un parti
révolutionnaire m2 parti socialiste un
parti qui est bien peu le psu et un
parti qui était un petit peu le parti
souhaitait d'abord le joueur croyances
et leur président et c'est à dire que
l'on était membre du 1er parti
socialiste qui était trop dur et trop
dur et il a préféré rejoindre un parti
qui est la vocation de rassembler tous
les socialistes y compris ceux qui
étaient plus modérées c'est bien 110
haies et il faisait partie de la gauche
je veux dire de ce parti là qu'il a
d'ailleurs quitté quelques mois avant sa
mort parce qu'ils le trouvaient trop
réformiste et comment expliquez vous que
l'on donne reste pour nous l'écrivain 2
enfance le côté que rod le côté gerges
en dehors grand nord chercheur d'or et
michael chelsea mais tout simplement
parce que le message que transporter
l'oeuvre de long dont effrayer ses
éditeurs et peut-être même le public de
l'époque et c'est la raison pour
laquelle a surtout rééditer de lui
délivre très beau mais qui était de lui
même assez inoffensif et pouvoir être
lue par un public familial comme on
disait à l'époque comme on dit encore
aujourd'hui et si bien qu'on a mis sous
le boisseau les trois quarts de son
oeuvre et que nous avons à l'heure
actuelle une image absolument fassi fier
de chaque round il existe une chance les
quatre volumes pratiquement inconnus à
part martin eden qui avait été un peu
réédité je me souviens bien vers le club
a livré ressortent maintenant en 10 18
et que vous allez ressortir bientôt
d'autres volumes oui des articles et des
romans oui en particulier tous ses
écrits socialiste qu'il s'agisse des ces
d'articles économique aux 22 critique
littéraire
très beau roman qui va paraître à la
rentrée qui s'appelle radio aurore qui
débute comme un roman d'aventurés dans
le grand nord et qui trompe les lecteurs
parce qu'en réalité c'est une méditation
sur l'enrichissement 6 part d'un
chercheur d'or qui est pourri par
l'argent qu'il a gagné une personnalité
sympathique scène est robuste et l'on
donne étudie sans altération sa
transformation au contact de l'argent la
fin des règlements du rail se passe à
dawson city je crois et vous avez tourné
un film sont non non non et vagabond
duras et c'est la période où l'on donne
suivi une armée de chômeurs c'était les
états unis traverser une crise
économique terrible un ouvrier sur
quatre avait perdu son travail c'était
dans 1894 london lité dans ce cas et il
a suivi les conseils d'un petit
industriel de loyaux qui étaient
scandalisés par l'inertie du pouvoir
fédéral car en vertu de la doctrine
libérale de l'époque le pouvoir fédéral
qui pourtant était aux mains des
démocrates se désintéresser de la crise
industrielle et trouvait que c'était aux
particuliers de résoudre leurs problèmes
c'était une affaire entre un industriel
et ouvrier en vertu de la liberté de
s'enrichir c'est à dire que c'était la
liberté comme disait déjà lacordaire au
19e siècle du renard libre dans le
poulailler libre et cet industriel a
invité cent mille chômeurs marché sur le
capitole à washington pour réclamer du
président des états unis qu'on
construise de bonnes routes sur tout le
territoire il est ko prépayées les
chômeurs et ses 5000 hommes qui se
déplaçait à washington vivait un peu sur
l'habitant francis à gaza écoutez je
suis navré mais on a des problèmes
d'horaires épouvantable on est débordé
donc on va malheureusement ne pas voir
ce que vous aviez tourné dans ce site il
te parler du tonnerre je voudrais qu'on
fasse quand même une minute sur un sujet
complètement différent pierre c'est
parce que larsen lupin c'est un sujet
d'étude c'est un personnage de notre
enfance c'est un
l'objet de analyse de professeurs de
l'école et sur ce politiques comme l'un
d'entre eux de finir ce soit qui nous
tend comme pat revenez et puis il sort
un larsen lupin à nouveau retenu
parfaitement il semblerait mort et bien
longtemps leur ont fait danser nue pas
nous était connu en long en large et en
travers on fait partie des du pineau man
si j'ose dire et puis on voit un arsène
lupin santé s'appelle le secret de
nervis c'est signé arsène lupin en toute
simplicité c'est à dire pas très bon et
les choses comme elles sont c'est
surtout pas trésor je sais pas très très
originale soit le bas de votre
excellent pastiche de recettes mais
c'est un pastiche c'est bien ça qui est
dommage on revoit des phrases de la
marie va de la femme ou de sourire non
rom et/ou des lignes de fou si vous vous
direz c'est essayer de dire en 30
secondes en 40 secondes qui étaient
retenus pain qui n est pas pour nous je
crois que c'est justement de
cambrioleurs mais enfin c'est notre
robin des bois français si j'ose dire
c'est à dire le celui qui vole aux
riches pour donner aux pauvres
je crois que c'est un c'est l'image
d'épinal qu'on a conservé dans ses menus
pas et qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
absolument inexact et si on reprenait le
verra la scène du pain dans un roman
très moderne qui aidera valais dans la
série noire mais qui finit mal alors
qu'arsenal va par définition finit bien
on pourrait appeler ça me redonne bruit
non pourquoi parce que c'est évident en
vie pourrie
peut-être enfin pour moi non lui pincer
d'autres choses en face et c'est un peu
inconscient projeté de milliers de
lecteurs qui ont pénétré par effraction
dans les coffres forts de gens plus
riches qu'eux mais maintenant on pense
plutôt disons arsène beau gars t'es un
vrai lupin non
je crois plus chercher une transition
je vois pas la transition car ces deux
matches on m'explique la transition
trendy pas edgar morin a par mégarde
alors normal terre et non alors là ça ne
l'est pas je ne sais pas mais évidemment
il faudrait parler ce livre le paradigme
eux perdu ce n'est pas si facile d'en
parler c'est pas que ce soit un livre
difficile a ni arrivées moi j'ai trouvé
très passionnant à lire mais je crois
que au lieu de parler d'une façon
précise de ce livre serait intéressant
pour une fois de parler de la personne
d' edgar morin en ce sens que ce qui est
intéressant finalement vous vous
intitulé chercheurs nous sommes tous des
chercheurs recherchons tous quelque
chose vous jouerez savoir
ce que vous cherchez je crois que cette
fois on commence à la paire soir d'une
façon plus précise pas ce que vous
cherchez sur toutes sortes de terrain
vous avez mis sous votre mii strophes ce
que vous avez écrit des livres sur le
monde du cinéma vous avez écrit un livre
sur la rumeur damien par exemple
certaines aires certains phénomènes qui
surgissent comme ça dans la société vous
avez écrit ce journal de californie dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure si vous
avez regardé encore la société d'une
certaine façon qui alors là vous
élargissez complètement le terrain et
vous fait un livre d'anthropologie avec
vous expliquer là dessus et notamment de
la paix de la sociologue ghislaine pas
impuni anthropologue ni sociologue où
vous commencez par constater que vous
partez presque de l'écologie n'est ce
pas mot qui était très rare il ya
quelques années qui maintenant est
devenu un mot courant et vous constatez
que par exemple dans les sociétés très
évolués d'entreprises auxquelles vous
consacrez premier chapitre de votre
livre il n'y a pas de hoerdt entre
l'individu et la société mais une espèce
de complémentarité ce que vous voulez
peut-être vous expliquer là dessus et
sur votre trajet personnel qui fait que
vous aboutissez à ce livre bon ben je
suis chercheur voir que je suis
chercheur professionnellement puisque
sur au cnrs mais je crois être aussi
personnellement c'est à dire que je
cherche dire je ne sais pas très bien ce
que je vais trouver quand je cherche je
prends très au sérieux ce terme alors je
cherche dans la science de l'homme et
quand on dit que j'aime pas
me dire ce lock c'est parce que pour moi
je ne veux pas très clairement où sont
les frontières entre le sociologique le
psychologique l'économique l'historique
et cetera alors cherchez quoi je me pose
sans arrêt la question que tout le monde
se pose ou du moins tout le monde se
pose quand on est enfant quand on
commence à réfléchir c'est qui sommes
nous où sommes nous et quel est ce monde
dans lequel nous vivons alors en effet
dans ce zoo tournons-nous peut-être
d'abord oui il faut si oui or dans ce
livre j'ai repris cette question avec le
maximum d'emplois que je pouvais lui
donner car depuis le début du siècle
s'était passé une terrible coupure entre
la science de l'homme et la science de
la nature on faisait comme si
brusquement l'homme notre ancêtre homo
sapiens avec cette grosse tête que nous
avons avait surgi à plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'années et il invente la
société il invente le langage il invente
le culte la culture et par là même il se
montre radical monde tous les animaux or
non seulement nous sommes des êtres
animaux parce que la bouche pour
laquelle je parle sert aussi à manger et
à bien d'autres usages mais aussi parce
que nous sommes des primates et bien
entendu il était important de savoir
quel type de soudure quel type de lien
nous avons avec le monde du vivant et
depuis une dizaine d'années ce problème
a pu être
reposée au lieu de ce gouffre insondable
on commence à voir deux branches qui
s'avance l'une vers l'autre or la
première branche en effet c'est l'étude
des animaux des mammifères et
singulièrement des sages supérieur qui
nous montre que la société existe chez
eux une société complexe qu'il existe
déjà des quasi classe sociale et que du
reste déjà ce niveau là se pose le
problème de la domination du groupe des
mâles sur celui des femelles et sur
celui des jeunes on se rend compte que
notamment les chimpanzés ont une
affectivité très riche et ont une
intelligence remarquable car
contrairement à ce que l'on continue à
croire malgré pasteur il n'ya pas de
génération spontanée en matière
d'intérêts gensse nous sommes les
héritiers d'une intelligence de la vie
et d'un autre côté les études de
préhistoire depuis dix ans nous montre
qu'il ya plusieurs millions d'années il
y avait un petit bipèdes avec une petite
tête pas plus grosse que celle d'un
chimpanzé qui avait un médecin et qui
déjà dans la savane fabriquer des outils
et construisaient des abris et on se
rend compte aujourd'hui en essayant
d'imaginer un roman-fiction delattre
histoire mais avec pas mal d'un disent
que c'est ce petit être ou plutôt les
hominiens qui ont succédé qui ont
développé la société qui ont créé la
culture pour développer le sillage
autrement dit on se rend compte que ce
que je aussi est-ce qu'il ya gratuit car
ça c'est un propos important d'être bien
sûr mais ce que je veux dire aussi c'est
une somme les héritiers du jeu ni mal
mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que on se rend
compte que nous homo sapiens on est
produit dans le fond par cette évolution
par la culture qui a préexisté par
l'outillage heures quelle est notre
différence mais quand on regarde aussi
les témoignages tourist avec la
différence c'est la sépulture c'est que
pour nous brusquement la différente
animaux la mort est quelque chose qui
est troublant qui est perturbant et on
imagine servi ce sont les peintures ubs
c'est le destin c'est la projection de
l'imagination c'est le rêve qui sort de
l'intérieur du sommeil qui va dans dans
le reste de la vie et c'est une sorte de
désordre inouïe qui va être source de
destruction épouvantable et aussi de nos
créations les plus géniales et aussi
jeudi que l'homme l'homo sapiens
apparaît comme un animal doué de
déraison par rapport aux autres animaux
et j'essaye de suivre alors depuis cette
époque jusqu'à maintenant les multiples
naissance de l'humanité
bien sûr il mais je serais quand même
posé de questions et de la morale crois
que même très très rapide la nature
humaine pour séville balançoire du 19e
siècle mais la différence quand même que
qui a entre le primate et nous c'est
qu'on a le sens de l'histoire et par e
mail à bosse bien d'autres différences
mais je sais que l'hôpital mais je ne
boirai de médiation visant jacques
sapir ce plateau qui n'a pas parlé et
que j'aurai même aimé entendre c'est la
femme demeure un come on a demandé à
maurin qu'il était qui nous a répondu
par une théorie de l'humanité j'ai envie
de ramener davantage un timing
pour vous oui john edgar morin c'est
quoi c'est quoi s y
est pas pour qui est le gars qui je suis
où quinon qui est celle
qui est en hausse et johanne
lépine dans la tautologie
jétais laissez moi bien sûr mais c'est
déjà été dit a très longtemps c'est
parce que c'était
très bien je voudrais pour terminer
cette émission ce soir qui a été trop
courte à notre goût parce que nos
invités avaient tous du talent genre
valter voulait encore vous parler de
réadmission par les non il fallait
signaler la réédition de 3
d'helvétius de l'esprit de fontenay les
entretiens sur la pluralité des mondes
et enfin de l'origine des espèces de
darwin marabout universités il m'a posé
des questions là-dessus à edgar morin
mais je crois que non je crois que ont
terminé cette édition maintenant il veut
vous remercie et je vous dis à vendredi
prochain bonsoir
[Musique]